Can my slow growing cancer suddenly or gradually get we just answered that question that can change on a regular basis and it can be because the cancer found a new fuel source.
It can be because your immune system was compromised.
The vaccine with this vaccine that's out that cancers have taken off not just with people that were vaccinated, but if you're around people that are vaccinated and you end up with with
just vaccine particles and spike proteins.
And it's just you can't argue that fact, though, that it's suppressed by the medical establishment and suppressed by the media.
The vaccine is caused cancers to literally just explode.
We've seen it here in our little TV media clinic and it is definitely nationwide. They've actually changed the death.
Statistics that a lot of people that have passed away with cancer and they've labeled them as passing away with the co-borbidity. So what's common with, you know, let's say lung cancer person passes away with stage four lung cancer.
And it's the same as pneumonia death in order so that they skew the statistics. I know that sounds very construed story but it's just true.
So that's just one aspect that can increase the goal to the cancer stress is another thing.
To increase about a stress in your life, something drastic has happened in your relationships or in your family and your stress goes way up and you hear this quite often that a person's cancer just starts going crazy again.
So there's all sorts of things. Why does stress do that? The stress is a stimulant of your sympathetic nervous system. That's why we encourage you guys to stay doing coffee in a bus because that's going to stimulate your parasympathetics.
Look at that. The forums that I have on the website and I have an on the,
remember site on different, those different functional medicine functional neurology exercises to stimulate your parasympathetics and to call your sympathetic.
Those are really important. They're silly, but they're important to they actually work. So don't discount doing those kind of things.
Your parasympathetic nervous system is your neurological control of all your detox case pathways as well as neurological control of your immune system.
So the more you could do to stimulate your parasympathetics and to suppress or call me your sympathetic told the better you're going to be.